we've been walking since before sunrise  even holdall tire Oh even you sweet  giant Oh hold on it's all right I don't  they teach you to say thank you more for  the wall you've got a big mouth girl and  too many teeth stop it you've been  fighting since you met just stop it  what's he going on about  and how come he always gets to sit and  chat while we do all the work  hold on there's a storm coming Oh make  you shut up if they hear us  [Music]  and I've heard all about Hodor Willis  I saw you as a boy you could talk look  what happened Hodor  I thought the hotel wasn't always Hodor  who his real name is Willis we can go  home now hold up well maybe not home  home but somewhere that isn't a cave  okay  he's something that isn't moss I would  an egg how'd you like him  boils with a russia of bacon and some  blood sausage